hi this is monisha Hara from Ruchi
reality Holdings Limited I'm into the
real estate business and I have come to
this summit and one thing to understand
about different aspects of the business
and industry I would like to tell you
about how important are the roles of the
states of India and the successful
implementation of local and national
reforms which have been done by them as
you know that India has large number of
states depending on the location on the
culture the number of states have gone
up and number of the value chain of the
states depending on their economic
conditions are changing today the
important states are Gujarat and
Maharashtra Tamil Nadu Karnataka these
are the very developed states in the
country and they are developed because
of their own local reasons the national
reasons are the same for all the states
but the local reasons the local
political zeal and local political
reasons to get these states in their
different positions depend on the local
leaders we have seen Gujarat under the
leadership of murine Modi we have seen
manipulation geing under leadership and
dynamic chief minister mr. Sher Singh
Chauhan and I think that all these
changes are very important for the
development of local body
as regards to the national reforms which
are implemented by the nile by the
central government the national reforms
are moving very slow which makes the
country or with the states go backwards
depending on their situations like the
state of manipulation we are facing a
lot of problems with the environment
ministry as the different areas are not
being opened for the coal blocks or for
the idea of mining or for different
mining activities which is making the
state go backwards which is not in other
states where the forest cover is not
there so it depends on the local and
national reforms I feel that on this
world economic forum platform we have
learned many things we have got people
from different societies different
aspects of work and it's a very
informative and very great platform for
people to understand about business and
about the growth of the country and
about the world thank you very much